hey josh welcome to ramsay show
hey guys how y'all doing better than i
deserve what's up
fair enough fair enough um so little
context
i'm a new listener um and first-time
homebuyer
and yeah this market as i'm sure you're
aware
it's just kicking my butt um this
real estate market yeah yeah real
estate's um
you know buying a single-family home
yeah um it's wild in it
yeah a little bit so my question for you
is um
you know i put a couple offers in you
know got blown out of the water because
you know everyone right now is
thinking about their emotions so it's
like i gotta have this house and you
know they're going 20 over asking
and i'm putting offers in for five over
asking
um i guess my question is
do i restructure my
my budget for a house because i've got a
sizeable down payment
you know and luckily that makes you know
pretty decent money
how much do you have down and how much
you make so i've got down about 50 to
60.
good and i make around 100 000 days
good how old are you i turned 26 this
week actually
good for you you're single yep oh well
i'm gonna you know yeah yeah but you're
not are you married you're not married
okay good no i wasn't asking about your
dating life i just asked if you're
married okay
the uh uh so a single guy 26 making 100
was 60 saved well done sir
very well done no debt josh
no pay for car and cash you know i got
one credit card just for
two percent cash back that i pay off no
club every month no student loans um
you know people sometimes yeah okay all
right
so so um what you're calling about is
down in your heart you have recognized
that people have lost their freaking
minds
absolutely and you're trying to not join
you're trying to not join the crazy
parade
please don't exactly right like i gotta
text my real estate agent today she was
like
yeah they're going with another offer
yeah and she's she's she's
she's the drum major at the crazy parade
yeah
sure yeah she's just trying to keep all
the stuff in order here
well she wants you to buy a house and if
you don't go crazy you're not gonna buy
a house right now
so here's the thing have you ever seen
one of those movies or ever been to a
live
auction where they're auctioning off
something
oh yeah like the jabbering auctioneers
yeah yeah and
there's an old one with the old comedian
jerry lewis and dean martin or something
at auction and
he kept scratching his nose and
accidentally bidding and all this stuff
you know what i'm talking about
but what happens at an auction is people
get excited
and in the exuberance and the emotion of
the moment they overpay for stuff
and that really does happen that's why
it makes a great movie scene as well
that makes sense yeah really that's what
you're in the middle of
yeah so you need to you need to
emotionally steal yourself
put a buffer up in your emotions
psychologically
called your intellect that says i am
willing
regardless of how many crazy butt people
are around me
to pay x for this house
if it goes for x plus 20 grand that is
god saying i'm not supposed to get this
house
yeah fair enough um i mean
it's every house though that i put in
hey
josh it's the market but you know what
you think it's gonna be every house for
a decade
no no think it's gonna be that way for
two years no
it might be that way till christmas it
may be next year before you buy a house
but don't get in the crazy parade
and josh why are you in a rush to get
into a house not really there's nothing
to go on fire here yeah
you're young you got some money yeah
i know i've been i've been dying for my
own space you know
well go get an apartment okay what are
you living at home
so yeah we're we're renting a home right
now okay um
all right so rent a home big deal don't
join the crazy parade don't do it bro
it's listen if you can buy a house and
you have done it in a way that you feel
proud about how you did it instead of
ashamed
that you joined the crazy parade then
buy a house i'm okay with that
i'm okay putting in some bids but don't
overpay i looked at a house the other
day for fun there was a million dollars
over the comps the dude is smoking
crack all he's doing is fishing for the
king of the crazy parade
i'm not in the crazy parade so i just
kind of looked at him and i went dude
i'm going to stand back over here and
watch this this is a spectator sport
right this is not a game i want to get
in so we'll stand back and watch and if
some idiot wants to pay that for it
that's fine but over comps
no man just calm your butt down take a
cold shower you got house fever